you've uh proposed that from a game
design perspective the thing that makes
chess
compelling as a game
uh is that there's a creative tension
between a bishop
and
the knight
can you explain this first of all it's
really interesting to think about what
makes a game compelling
makes it stick across centuries
yeah i was sort of thinking about this
and actually a lot of even amazing chess
players don't think about it necessarily
from a games designer point of view so
it's with my game design hat on that i
was thinking about this why is chess so
compelling
and i think a critical uh reason is the
the dynamicness of of of the different
kind of chess positions you can have
whether they're closed or open and other
things comes from the bishop and the
knight so if you think about how
different the the the capabilities of
the bishop and knight are in terms of
the way they move and then somehow chess
has evolved to balance those two
capabilities more or less equally so
they're both roughly worth three points
each so you think that dynamics was
always there and then the rest of the
rules are kind of trying to stabilize
the game well maybe i mean it's sort of
i don't know his chicken and egg
situation probably both came together
but the fact that it's got to this
beautiful equilibrium where you can have
the bishop and knight they're so
different in power um but so equal in
value across the set of the universe of
all positions right somehow they've been
balanced by humanity over hundreds of
years um i think gives gives the game
the creative tension uh that you can
swap the bishop and knights uh for a
bishop for a knight and you you they're
more or less worth the same but now you
aim for a different type of position if
you have the knight you want a closed
position if you have the bishop you want
an open position so i think that creates
a lot of the creative tension in chess
you